In Python, we can write a comment that extends to the end of the line
by prefacing it with the # sign or the pound sign or the hash sign.
JavaScript has this same idea, but instead
the comments start with // and then continue to the end of the line.
This time I'll write the rule for you.
Here's a rule corresponding to comments that go to the end
of the line in JavaScript.
They start with a slash and then another slash,
and then you can have anything that's not our special newline character,
as many of those as you want, and the maximal munch rule
means we're going to eat up all of those characters that we possibly can.
And then rather than returning that as a token, we throw it away
because it's a comment, documentation for the user.
Let's test our knowledge of this rule with a quiz.
I've written out 4 sequences of input,
and I'd like you to indicate which of these 4 sequences would yield
identifier, identifier, number
given the rules we've been talking about for JavaScript.
You've seen how we define identifiers, how we define numbers,
and what starts an end of line comment.
Here are 4 different lines.
Which ones give us identifier, identifier, number?